what are you doing here no time to
explain
woody and Bo Peep are reuniting what are
you living through reunited I love it
Toy Story 4 trailers here alongside a
lot of new friends and we haven't seen
Bo since 2002 it's been too long
too long we're gonna break down the new
characters and some theories about Toy
Story 4 or have one did this trailer do
it for you it did do it for me it did I
am NOT a toy I was paper suit salad
maybe chili and then the trash okay so
the premise here is that Bonnie the kid
that they get with at the end of toys
Story 3 made a toy in class called forky
it's like a fork with like pipe cleaners
and forkie has like an existential
crisis about being a spork and then goes
on the run that's kicking off an
adventure yes very 2019 and at some
point they come across an antique shop
with Bo and these new like really creepy
characters because let's face it antique
shops are really creepy especially I
mean just in general I think they're
creepy hi my name is Gabby Gabby
we can't stay yes you can boy okay so
let's run through some of the new
characters announced today christina
hendricks voices gabby gabby now she is
a pull-string doll from the 1950s has a
manufacturing defect in her voice box
and she spent more than 60 years in the
antique shop her only companions are
creepy voiceless ventriloquist dummies
creepy I've seen goosebumps I don't like
it and then Keanu Reeves the voices Duke
kaboom a 1970s toy based on Canada's
greatest stuntman but he has an Achilles
heel he has never been able to do the
awesome stunts as advertised in his own
toy commercial yeah yeah now Ali Maki
voices giggle make dimples a miniature
plastic doll from the 80s
she's Bo's best friend on her shoulder
yeah like a little Jiminy Cricket that's
how they described her I don't know you
can on the tip yeah out of those three
who are you most excited Keanu Reeves
and hands down and they're the producers
didn't interview where they said that
Keanu got up on the table and was doing
Duke kaboom poses can we see that so
please release that footage we need to
get back to our kid Oh Sheriff woody
always come in to the rescue can I throw
out a hot theory yes
all right brace yourselves I think that
this is a different bull peep and she's
the villain blew my mind right it makes
me think of the trailer in a little
different way but why do you think that
okay something seems a little off about
her and yes it's the same voice actors
it's Annie Potts so there's you know
that's not the reason but the way she
kind of like smirks she's mentioned
something about not letting would he
leave the antique shop like why would
she want him to stay that sketchy yeah
and she seems so against being in the
kid world again now I get it she's a
lost toy so you can be jaded you cannot
want to go back but something seems
weird and also who's the villain then
who's the villain maybe we didn't see
the villain in the trailer no Pete I
think this is the only thing throwing me
off about this is that Tim Allen
described this movie as a love story but
that could be like his misdirect that
Disney was like keep saying that mm-hmm
take a listen see for yourself both Tom
and I who met yesterday for our little
guy lunch had we both very very affected
by the end of the movie so much so that
he had to we said the same thing he had
to turn around he could even deliver his
end of it I couldn't deliver my end of
it it's a wonderful full bodied movie
they've taken this in a direction that
is spectacular but not you go oh that I
can't believe I haven't thought of that
before these writers have done something
amazing the characters they develop for
amazing it's a love story between Tom
and his love interest but he's a toy I
mean it is what it is and then buzz has
to make a decision on how to move on
with his life because it's a Tom's
making some differences at Woody's
making some different decisions and
that's all I can tell you I'm just
saying that it's so funny and so bright
in so interesting and so effective
towards the end
ash are you emotionally ready for this
one because I'm not no I'm not I'm not
I'm not my novel itself is not ready
they were like this is the last toy
story toy story 3 and then boom now we
have to a story for here we go I'm not
ready
messing with our emotions again now what
are your Toy Story four theories we
obviously want to know ash has a really
good one is my Bo Peep Theory crazy let
us know I'm ash Carlson and I'm Kourtney
teza know to infinity and beyond
[Music]